(upbeat music)
- Well, welcome to another
episode of the Addy Hour.
It's my pleasure to be able
to host these conversations,
and to really continue
to talk about topics
that I think are essential
and important for us
as a society.
And so today I'm, again honored
to be able to welcome two guests
from different walks of life,
who are gonna be able to share
their unique experiences,
but also share some parallels
and overlapping themes as well.
The topic for today's conversation
will be where do we go from here.
And I think in a lot of ways
this is a highly relevant topic
and conversation.
I mean, to be completely honest,
it seems like we're just
going from one tragic event
to the next on a weekly basis,
sometimes on a daily basis.
And so I think it's
really important for us
to be able to sit back
and process how we
actually move through that.
So I'm honored to be able
to host today's two guests.
The first is Dr. Amy Arnsten.
And Amy Arnsten is the
Albert E. Kent Professor
of psychology and neuroscience at Yale.
She directs a research
lab where she looks at
and researches the processes
and circuits in the brain
that are affected by stress and by aging,
and how those can lead
to cognitive deficits.
She's made a whole host
of different research,
seminal research contributions
to the field over the years.
She's also a member of the prestigious
National Academy of Medicine.
And so we're thrilled to
have Amy here with us.
One thing I will say, one of
the things I really appreciate
in addition to all the accolades
is how Amy leads with passion.
This is something that you
can see in the classroom
when she's teaching, in the research lab
and then how she engages in society.
So Amy, welcome to the Addy Hour,
definitely grateful to have
you here with us today.
- Thank you so much Nii, a joy to be here.
- Our second guest is
none other than Lecrae.
Lecrae is a multi Grammy award
winning (indistinct) artist,
who has evolved into a New
York Times bestselling author,
entrepreneur, speaker, thought
leader, and philanthropist,
all while co owning
and serving as president of Reach Records.
So he's someone who's had a lot of impact
in a lot of different spheres.
He's also sold millions of
copies of his music worldwide.
He has won multiple Grammy
Awards, Dove Awards,
a Soul Train Music Award
and also had a BET hip hop nomination.
But again, addition to all the accolades,
one thing I really appreciate about him
is how invested he is in community
and how he has continued
to make those investments
in several different ways.
One of those more recent
has been all the initiatives
that he's taken part in
and really trying to rebuild
the West side of Metro Atlanta.
In addition to other things that he's done
in the Atlanta area and worldwide.
So really grateful to have
Lecrae here on the program
with us today as well,
thanks for being here.
- Honored, honored, sincerely.
- So we're ready to jump
into this conversation
and excited to really think
deeply about this aspect
of where do we try and go from here.
For any of you who are regular listeners,
one of the things I like
to do is really to check in
with our guests first, just
to see how you're doing
in the midst of everything
that's going on.
Clearly this has been
another tragic week for us
as a society with ongoing
killings of black men and boys
at the hands of police.
And it's heavy, I mean, that's
a honestly heavy place to be.
I mean, I can say personally,
a lot of times I moved through
a lot of different emotions
when those things come up.
There's a feeling
sometimes of personal fear,
just being completely honest.
There's feelings of frustration, anger,
there's feelings of
exhaustion and tiredness.
And sometimes I know I even shift
towards being a little bit numb
to just seeing this kind of
happening over and over again.
And then at the same time I
know that I have a deep need
and desire for healing and hope.
So it's really a mixture of things
and it kind of moves depending on the day
and where I'm at any
specific point in time.
But I thought it would be
really good for all of us,
the three of us here and for our listeners
to really at least start
out talking through
how you're dealing with
everything that's going on
in society and even in
your personal lives.
So Amy, if we could go
ahead and start with you
if you'd be willing to share.
- Sure, and I also feeling weary
from such a continued stress.
Much of the past year for me personally,
I was so worried about my mother who's 99,
which is wonderful, but
she was in an assisted
living facility and it was a
real race between the virus
and the vaccine and thank
God she got the vaccine.
And it was the same
thing with the election,
where it was just this
overwhelming anxiety.
And thankfully Biden won.
But at this point when I have
this very childish feeling of,
"Oh, can't it all be all better now."
And instead dealing now
with the real problems
that are still very much there.
So for example, my mother has gone blind
and how to help her.
And then at a national level,
today as we talk just the national anxiety
about what's gonna happen
in the Chauvin trial.
And I think over the past four
years, so much got exposed
about the many weaknesses in America
that we had so hoped
had really been solved
a lot more than it has.
And this realization, we
have a long way to go.
And
that's going to take a lot of help.
We have to really take care
of ourselves and each other
if we're going to make progress.
And to relate to today's
conversation, I find for myself
that understanding how the
brain responds to stress
has really helped me have
compassion for myself
when I'm feeling inadequate
and not living up to what I hope to be.
And I think it's wonderful
to have this opportunity
to share this here today,
'cause I think compassion and forgiveness,
whether they come from
science or religion or art,
helps us to heal and can give
us that strength we need.
- That's so well said.
Thank you for sharing, so honestly about,
even the personal challenges and what,
the places that you find hope and healing
in the midst of this as well.
Lecrae, what about you?
How are you managing
at this current moment?
- Well, it's interesting.
I think, 2016 is when I
really, 2014 through 16,
is when I really found
myself hyper-focused
on a lot of the racial tensions
and political tensions in America.
And I did not consider how it
would personally affect me.
I think I just went in blind
and not recognizing the real,
I didn't understand the
science of stress or anxiety
or depression, any of those things.
And I just stuffed all of
those emotions and feelings
deep down inside
which ultimately resulted
in a mental breakdown.
And I think from 2018 until now,
I'm so much more aware of
what hyper-focusing on all
of those particular things
can do to me, and so I
think in this season of life
I'm working to process solutions,
I'm working to process how we can navigate
and positive things that we
can do in light of it all.
Because I think you can become
a nihilist in a lot of ways
if you just look at how
crazy everything is.
So for me, I've been trying to be helpful
in as many ways as possible.
I've been trying to figure
out how do we invest
in potential Dante Wrights,
invest in the younger
generation of George Floyds
to create awareness and insight
so that they can find themselves
in a healthier place in life.
And then at the same time thinking through
what it looks like to communicate
empathy to law enforcement
and people on the other side of the aisle.
And so all that to say,
to get super scientific
for some people, I am
believing in neuro-plasticity,
I am trying to focus on new things
so that changes can happen and
healing can occur in my mind.
(All laughing)
- Well said, well, I was
joking before we got on there,
we're gonna flip the roles a little bit,
have Lecrae expand on the neuroscience
and have Amy talk about
her experiences with music.
(All laughing)
And there's room for that,
there's room for that.
But I appreciate you sharing a little bit
of the journey as well, and
both of what you've shared,
both from personal experiences
and what you've tried to do.
Lecrae I'd be curious to
hear you expand on that,
even a little bit more on what you,
'cause you talked about how
you've gotten to this place.
What have you seen be
effective in your journey?
And on the flip side, things
that you would also say
that have been ineffective,
that you would have avoided
or that you would do
differently going forward.
- Yeah, I think one is
understanding your limitations.
There are certain things
that you can know about
but you may not need to see.
And I think in the age we're in,
I'm grateful for the
accountability of video
but it doesn't mean I need
to watch all the videos.
It doesn't mean that's healthy for me
to see people being murdered via video.
And so part of it for me is not
inundating myself with that,
with those visuals, figuring
out, okay, what am I doing?
What kinds of things can
I do that make me feel
like I'm investing and
I'm working toward change?
I think that's been helpful for me.
And then more or less is
in light of everything
going on societally, is
I've had to find myself,
where does my hope lie?
And what am I grateful for?
And how can I meditate on
those particular things
more often?
The things that I wish I
would have done different is
I think that I found
myself very hyper-focused
on all of the negativity, and
I did not look historically
at the change that had occurred
and that what it may take
to see more change occur.
I just looked at kind of the
pessimistic side of everything,
and I just found myself very low and very,
it was a dark time.
And if I could go back, I
think I would have learned
that hyper-focusing on all of
that was not healthy for me.
- Yeah, that makes a lot of sense.
And I think that's something
we'll probably come back to
in this conversation
to, even thinking about
how we get into that hyperfocused state
and what's happening in our brain,
that allows that to occur
and ways to even manage that.
I think it's also great that
you brought the idea of hope
and healing as well.
And Amy, you were hinting
at that and mentioning that
when you talked about your perspective
with neuroscience as well.
So I'd be curious if you
could share for our listeners
how you got into this journey
or your journey to get to this place
of thinking about the neuroscience
of stress and resilience.
And then also how that
helps you even more so
with the hope that you were talking about.
- Sure, I actually began wondering
about neuroscience and
stress when I was a teenager.
We had a lot of illness
and death in my family,
with loved ones when I was that age.
I watched as like my
parents, people around me,
who you rely on as a kid and
suddenly they're this swirl.
There's a quick sand there,
you can't rely on them anymore
'cause they weren't thinking straight.
I actually began volunteering
at the State Psychiatric
Hospital in New Jersey
to learn more about mental illness.
And it shows how old I
am that this was a time
when there were these huge
hospitals, 2,000 patients.
And you can argue whether that was better
than having people out
on the street, homeless.
But volunteering there I got to know
several patients quite well.
And one gentleman had schizophrenia
and had been an astrophysicist,
and we were able to talk
about astronomy in this great way,
totally logical, you'd
never know he was ill.
And then one day, while we're doing that
someone mentioned the name
of this really cruel doctor.
And just hearing that man's name
this gentleman just instantly dissolved
into what's called word
salad, thought disorder,
one clanging phrase after another
that really didn't make sense.
And then as he calmed down,
his thoughts (indistinct)
and we continued our talk
about the solar system.
And it was like this
explosive seed crystal to me.
This shows I have to understand
what stress does to the brain,
because it's such a clue
as to what's underlying
so many disorders,
including schizophrenia.
And so I've really studied it ever since.
And thankfully we've been able
to make a lot of progress,
and what we've learned, we,
meaning the field as well as me,
that when you have a stress
that makes you feel out of
control, that's a key part of it,
if you feel up to it, these
toxic changes don't happen.
But if you feel threatened
or out of control,
you get this flood of chemicals
that takes what's called the
prefrontal cortex offline.
And the prefrontal cortex is
one of our most newly evolved
parts of our brain that
subserves abstract reasoning,
top-down control.
So you really need it
when you're going through
a complex stressor in particular.
And at the same time this
flood of stress chemicals
strengthens our primitive circuits
that make us unconsciously reacts,
our emotional reactions and habits.
So it's this double whammy
where you're losing your
rational cheerleader
and at the same time strengthening
these primitive reactions.
And your brain can really get in a rut
where it develops a vicious
cycle and gets stuck there.
And so a large part of what
my lab is trying to do,
is understand what is it that
makes prefrontal cortex weak
versus stronger, so we
can develop medication.
So if you're in a rut
you can get some help
on getting to a healthier place.
So it's been a long journey
cause I'm an old woman,
but I can really place it back (chuckles)
to those childhood experiences.
- Yeah, that's really powerful,
I mean, to know that
that initial experience
had such a long-term impact on you,
in your trajectory, in your passion,
I think that that says a
lot in the fact that you're,
I mean, it sounds like you're
motivated by the people
that you're serving in
a lot of ways as well.
- Yeah, very much,
and sometimes that person's me. (chuckles)
- So what, I'd be curious to
hear even more about that.
How does that part come into
play, the person being you?
Because I know it's attention
and sometimes there are ways
that different of us as
scientists kind of reconcile that
in different ways, so
it'd be great to hear,
how you've done that over the years.
- Well, some of it is when
I find myself losing it.
Lecrae was saying, finding your limits.
And I've also really come to say,
"Okay, I can feel that
my brain is not going
into a good place, stop watching
the news for hours on end.
Let's go for a walk in the woods that,
knowing what your own limits are
and what makes you feel better,
which is individual for
everybody, but learning that.
And so you can take
care of yourself better.
And I'm also taking one of the medications
my lab discovered, but
that's cause I'm an old lady
and not just as a stressed person.
(all laughing)
- Yeah, well I mean, I
think that's powerful
in a lot of ways, and I
appreciate your honesty
in sharing that as well.
- Who can say that?
Who say, "I'm taking a
medication my lab discovered."
That's like, I have no
comprehension of this, is amazing.
- It is, it is, it's a good point.
- We don't know if it's working though.
(laughing loudly)
- We can, we can ask those around you.
I have a feeling they would
say it's working. (chuckles)
Lecrae, how do you, I
mean, you react to it,
but how do you react to even components
that Amy's talking about
in terms of how the brain's working?
Like does that, hearing that
now and thinking backwards
to what you've already talked about
does that give you even a way to interpret
some of the things that you were saying?
- Yeah, I mean, it's just, I'm fascinated,
I think like organizing chaos
is something that's
very fascinating for me,
and I think the idea
that I walk through life
and all the chaos that just ensues
and I didn't have categories
for what was happening.
I didn't have language for it like,
"Oh, this is stress I'm
feeling," you know what I mean?
I don't think I had a context for it.
And then even to go steps
deeper and talk about,
well my prefrontal cortex
isn't working properly
and all those things are very helpful.
Some things are just obvious to us.
I really, I'm grateful for the
kind of playing field being leveled
as it pertains to mental health,
more so because I don't think people think
it's as scientific as it is.
I think they find themselves
connecting their brain
to their essence, like your
identity in a lot of ways.
And your biology is not the
full extent of your identity.
Sometimes, it's kinda of like right now,
like people don't know I'm
wearing contact lenses.
But my identity is not that I can't,
I don't think of like, "Oh
my gosh, I need contact,
so I'm a terrible person,"
you know what I mean?
I don't think like that.
I think how can I fix this
blindness that I suffer from?
Do I wear some glasses?
Do I put in some contacts?
And then I can move forward.
But it's not like a crushing
weight on my worth and my value
but oftentimes my brain not
functioning as it should,
like a disorder you tend
to say, "I'm terrible."
You know what I mean like,
I didn't know, like I have
ADD, I don't know if it's ADHD,
but it definitely ADD, and
I didn't know that as a kid,
I just thought I was as
impulsive, mischievous,
irrational person, and
now as an adult it's like,
"Oh, I wish I would've known that."
And so I think it's very
insightful and it's comforting
to hear Amy talk about these
things, it gives me comfort.
- Yeah, that's really well said
- I'm so glad, 'cause
it does that for me too.
- Yeah.
I think that's a place
that we all need to be
in a lot of the ways.
I mean, even the point that you brought up
about leveling the playing field.
Not to be too pejorative
to those as academics,
but we have this tendency
to get stuck in our bubble.
You don't talk to
anybody about the science
outside of that bubble.
And then we don't even
interpret it for our own selves.
So, I mean, Amy I think
everything you're talking about,
I mean, I see that as
unique in a lot of ways
as reflective as you've
been about your work
and your own emotions as
you're walking through that
and being able to, I mean,
the fancy word people use
is metacognition, to be able
to think about your thinking
and what you're going
through while it's happening.
And to be able to have those tools,
I think it makes it even
that much more powerful
to talk about your experience
so that those outside
of the scientific realm can learn from it
and actually apply it and
see that we're applying it
in our own lives as well, I
mean, I think that's huge.
- Well, and just a reminder that often
you can't do that in the moment,
'cause stress is taking
exactly those circuits offline.
But then not being mad at
yourself about that and going back
and revisiting and having that.
- Yeah, yeah, so true.
- I don't think people sit
back and tell themselves like,
"Oh man, my prefrontal
cortex is short-circuiting
right now," like, yeah-
- I do.
(laughing loudly)
- So, I mean, on that note
that's actually a great segue
'cause I'm curious, we started this,
thinking about where do we go from here?
How do we take all these principles
that you all are talking
about and apply them right now
in our current situation?
Maybe not in the moment as we're seeing
and another unjust killing occurring,
but in this moment as we're conversing
and thinking about how we're
going to deal with that,
if and when it happens again.
Amy any thoughts you wanna
jump in with to start off?
- I wanna go back to what we just said
to add one more thought
that I think it's helpful
to think of mental health
as a continuous spectrum.
That there's this continuum
between health and illness,
and also that a strength in one context
can be a weakness in
another, including with ADD,
there's times when having
that kind of energy
and being distracted by
something that's just occurred
can be life-saving for
a person or a community
who's with that person.
So I think that helps reduce
stigma and, and gives us,
it's both more realistic, but
also more compassionate view
about brain health and the recognition
that if you've had either genetic insults,
a physical insult, an
emotional or physical trauma
that those are times when
you need extra self-care,
recognizing limits that can shift
and one can be more fragile
as Lecrae was talking about.
So really taking care
of our minds, brains,
the way many people take
care of their bodies
with working out.
And I think some people are
already trying to do that
with like drinking caffeine,
but doing it in a much
broader way with all the needs
and that can help give
us more effective view
on mental health.
For what you were just saying this idea of
how do we help ourselves
feel more in control
and give ourselves what we
need to be able to help ourself
be our better self again,
and it's so individual.
So it's, again you have to
really know who you are,
what are your triggers?
What are the things that
help to make you feel better
and important that they're the things
that don't make you feel
worse in the morning.
So alcohol, drugs can make
you temporarily feel better
but then you're worst.
What are the things that
give you sustained goodness?
Even if it isn't so dramatic instantly,
it's really there for
you for the long run.
And I think there's many things,
for some people it's things
like meditation and exercise.
Oh, and that reminds me,
I got a call once from Arianna Huffington,
who was writing a piece on
the civil rights leaders
of the 20th century and how
they had to do self care
to get themselves through the long haul.
And how like Rosa Parks did yoga.
And so they really recognize
something right from the start,
this is gonna be a very,
very long and hard mission.
We have to take care of ourselves.
And I think we have forgotten that
and are having to rediscover it.
And so the kinds of things
that can help people,
feeling gratitude, gaining
perspective from that,
from walking through the woods
is one of the things I like to do,
through community, through
artistic expression
and music in particular, I think can be
particularly effective 'cause
music is so much about emotion
both expressing it and
receiving it by listening to it.
And my son is also a musician.
So I get to watch this closeup
and I get to see the comments
on his YouTube videos,
just like with Lecrae's,
where people are saying, "I
have just lost this loved one
and your music has made
all the difference to me
giving me hope again."
Someone who is suicidal
and listening to the music,
gave them what they
needed to keep going on.
So I think blessings
rhyming with stressings
is really important Lecrae,
so thank you for that.
(laughing loudly)
- Well said.
I didn't know you were gonna
bring out some lyricism.
I'm very impressed.
(Amy laughing)
Very impressed.
- Bravo, bravo.
That's great, I would wholeheartedly agree
with so much of what she said.
I think, I look at my own
life in light of everything,
I was, I experienced a
lot of historic trauma.
I was abused.
I experienced neglect.
The men I looked up to
I was oftentimes visiting them in prison.
And so I didn't realize those
are all contributing factors
to my development and my mental health.
And so I look at it
like, the average person,
if you think about their stress
level as like a paper towel,
when you put, if you've got
a paper towel on top of a cup
or something like that, and
you put some, I don't know,
some rice on top of that paper
towel, it's gonna sink down,
but if there's like a
rubber band around it,
it'll sustain and hold the rice.
Well, I look at my historical trauma,
as like drips of water on my paper towel.
And so when someone puts the rice on it,
I'm more vulnerable.
I'm more vulnerable to having a breakdown,
to having that stress snap.
And I think that's what's
currently been helpful for me.
I didn't know this in 2014
through 2016, I didn't know that.
So I'm engaging these
stressful circumstances
not realizing that I'm dealing
with a wet paper towel.
And now, it's like I know, I
have a sensitive brain, right?
Like my brain is sensitive,
it's hypersensitive.
I get false alarms in terms
of anxiety all the time.
And so I have to,
and knowing that I can
think more rationally,
and I probably have to spend more time,
like she was just talking
about Rosa Parks doing yoga,
I spend more time meditating on truth.
I think if you,
they say that people who
know counterfeit money
they don't study counterfeit money,
they study real money so well,
that when they see counterfeit,
they can find, they can
pick it out immediately.
And that's kinda what I
find myself having to do.
I have to spend time
meditating on what is true
and what is good, and
not irrational things,
so that when this false alarm
gets triggered in my brain,
I can say, that's not what this is.
That's not what's happening right now.
And so, someone gets murdered
on national television,
I think it's stressful to anyone, right?
But for me, I can,
without having meditated on what's true,
I can get very irrational
and think this is the end.
it's gonna happen for me, this is,
I don't know, my kids are,
and I can just start spinning
out of control irrationally,
which makes chaos happen, and
so I have to meditate and say,
hey, listen, what's true about this?
Okay, can you absolutely prove
that someone's gonna kick in
your door tonight and kill your kids?
No, I can't, so let's not go there.
You know what I mean?
Let's not get too wound up
in that particular place.
And I found that that's
been very helpful for me,
is really meditating on what
I know is true to fight back
that hypersensitivity
going on in my brain.
- That's so good, and that
ties in it makes me think
of one of the points that
you made earlier too,
you're not to get too
far outside the scope
but you talked about
both sides of the aisle,
for us as black men in this country
but then also for those
who are in law enforcement.
'Cause I have friends
who are police officers
and if you've listened
to some of the commentary
with what happened to the individual
that was in the armed
services that got pulled over.
People have been talking
about the mental state
or the hypervigilant state
that the police were in
when they pulled that person over.
What was going through
their minds at that moment?
- Yes.
- And we also have to talk
about those situations too
and those individuals where they're coming
into that situation from.
- Yes.
- So I know, I mean, being
on the receiving end of that,
being pulled over, I was
coming back from a talk,
at Emory of all places
got back at one o'clock in the morning.
On the way home, lived in the part of town
that was kind of off the beaten path
and got pulled over at
one o'clock the morning
for no reason, so everything
that's running through my mind,
I was definitely in a hypervigilant state.
But then also thinking about
the Caucasian female officer,
who was walking up to my
car, what was in her mind?
So, I mean, just everything
you've mentioned,
I don't think we have
those conversations enough.
I don't know as much about
the law enforcement side
but I feel like it's
something that has to be heard
on both sides of the aisle.
That's definitely a live
conversation in a lot of ways.
So again, that could be a whole
nother topic of discussion.
But I think sometimes we don't
talk about what's happening
in the brains on both sides
and how once you put that together,
Amy I don't know if there's
anything you want to add
from your perspective
about those stressors
that come on both sides
of the aisle in that way.
- Oh yeah, (indistinct) empathy
is our way out, absolutely.
Now you can really understand
that when everybody's stressed
the worst things can happen
and forgiveness all around,
if you possibly can, how hard that is,
and then why deescalation
can be so helpful
and that there are programs
and people out there
who are actively trying
to provide deescalation.
Some of it based on neurobiology
to help people who are,
whose work constantly puts them
in these threatening situations.
- Yeah, I think that's so important.
And clearly it doesn't ignore,
it doesn't justify
anything that's happened
but I think it's a part
of the conversation
that we need to really
seriously talk about.
- Constructive way forward.
- Exactly.
And one idea that's been lofted out there
is that maybe you don't
have law enforcement respond
to every emergency that comes up, right.
If they're trained to respond
to violent criminal activity,
maybe they don't need to be called for,
something that doesn't
fall under that scale
because you're already
hypervigilant, as you said.
So you're not thinking to deescalate,
you're thinking, you're in
your fight or flight mode,
and it's just a speeding
ticket, you know what I mean?
When you're in fight or flight mode,
so maybe there's some
restructuring around all of that.
I have a friend as well,
Nii, who's a police officer,
and he told me a story of him,
he's a black man, but he's chasing down
someone who has committed a violent crime.
And it was like a domestic
abusive if I'm not mistaken.
And he catches him and the guy
starts fighting him violently
he's on drugs, and,
he was in a situation where he was like,
"Man, this guy is really dangerous."
And he had to make a
decision in that moment like,
as this guy broke through a
hold and took off running,
was it worth chasing after him
and getting into even more
violent circumstance or situation?
And he had to process that.
But the crazy part about it was,
after that call he's already,
his emotions and everything is heightened
and he's got to respond to another call
that's nowhere near the
same type of circumstances.
And how does he turn his
brain down, dial it down,
to deal with what's in front of him
when he's just left a brawl,
with a violent individual.
And so those are all the circumstances
that I don't think we're talking
about and we're processing.
- Yeah, yeah that's so true.
And Amy, all the,
I mean all the tools
you've been talking about
and the processes in the brain
that we need to be aware of,
it seems like they're
all coming into play,
will need to be an essential
part of those conversations.
- Yeah, and are there things
like people who are specialized
in dealing with mental health emergencies
who could be in that car
and there to help them.
Have pharmacological tools
to deal with somebody
who's really psychotic so that
things with physical force
don't need to be this much, yeah.
Much more thoughtful
ways of how to proceed
and protect the police as well
as the other people, yeah.
- Yeah, yeah, this is so important.
I mean, to be honest I can add something,
we'll probably have a more
full extended conversation
on this podcast at some point
'cause I think it's one that,
it's happening in small pockets,
but it really needs to be a much larger
and bigger conversation
in a lot of ways so-
- Yeah.
- I was curious just as we talked about
you both have music ties
but how do you see music
tying into this as well?
Amy you talked about the emotion.
How does the music tie in
both in terms of like
how we experience things
and in terms of the brain,
like what is the power that's there?
I'm putting you on the spot. (chuckles)
- I'll be very speculative.
So in right-handed individuals,
the left hemisphere is
usually what creates
and understands language
whereas the right hemisphere
creates and understands
emotion in language.
And to me, music is the right hemisphere
without necessarily the words.
And then of course we add words in songs.
But you don't even need those
to feel the emotion of songs.
So that's something I just wondered about.
It's thinking about music
as emotional expression
that doesn't even need words.
- That's well said.
- Yeah, I would not have been
able to say it like that,
that's great.
In my understanding in the
learning that I've had,
one of the realizations that I've had is
that I've been writing songs
since I was a little kid
and probably
around 2000 and, I wanna say the iPhone,
the iPhone in terms of like
writing and taking notes
and computers and whatnot,
I think that was more
revolutionary for me anyway
around 2011 and 2010 maybe.
And so I wonder this is just
me being speculative as well
but I wonder if all those
years that I spent time
actually using the motor
skills to write and to process
was helpful for my mental stability.
And as I began to switch
over and use the keyboard
and use my phone to write
was I not getting all the same benefits?
There was something therapeutic
about writing down those lyrics.
And also in light of what Amy just said,
I love creative expression.
I think it's very helpful for me.
I think it connects
with people, music does,
minor chords hit a certain type,
part of the mind in the brain,
major chords, get you more excited.
But when I have to
actually take the creative
musical expression and then
add concepts and words,
it becomes a little tougher.
It becomes a little more
like of a push uphill.
So I'm wondering if
there's something to that
and you might have nailed something there.
I know I need to have words
'cause it connects with people
but it's just very interesting
that I can get a kick out
of just playing on the keys
or hearing a jazz, saxophone solo,
and it still gives me that same emotion.
- And it's especially an uphill push
if you had to make those words rhyme.
(laughing loudly)
- Tell me about it,
(Nii laughing)
tell me about it.
Yeah I'm working on it.
- Wow, there's definitely something there.
I mean, I'm just thinking
back, not to disclose
too many Addy secrets,
my own song writing days
and just the nostalgia that
comes with it sometimes too.
Like if I hear something I
wrote 20 years, 25 years ago,
the place that it takes me back to,
(indistinct) that's not, I mean it's all,
the positive triggering
in a sense some ways
that's outside of my realm of expertise,
but you all are making me-
- Now we need to hear
this music, I didn't even-
(Nii and Amy laughing loudly)
- I knew that was dangerous. (chuckles)
- Don't worry, I won't
let you forget about it.
- I'm sure, we'll bring it out,
we'll bring it out in some
shape or form. (chuckles)
- So, Nii, I also wrote
songs when I was a teenager.
- Wow.
- The two of us should
put out an album together.
- Wow.
- Okay, lemme find out that
it's got to happen now,
we need that,
who knows when two
neuroscientists get together
what kind of songs are gonna
be created, we need that.
- Well, you gotta be pulled
into this mix too. (chuckles)
- All right, I'll see what I can do.
I'll see if I have anything to contribute.
The lyrics get a little too lofty for me.
Get a little too academic for
me, I'll try to be the person
to make it make sense
to the common person.
- I was ready for you to
make a neuro-science comment
when you were starting to follow Amy
with that comment about
the music and your writing.
I was getting really excited
about where you were gonna take it.
- Well, listen, I don't,
I know the little bit
that I do know, and I'm
understanding the motor skills
and the parts of the brain that
are trying to work together
and so on and so forth,
and so again, like I said,
I'm all about trying to find
as much healing as possible.
I'm honored to be able to be
in conversations like this
because I'm always wondering
like what are the new advances?
what's gonna happen, I mean,
look at what's happening?
We got my, I drive a car
that if I push a button,
it can navigate itself
through city streets,
we gotta figure something
out with the brain.
You know what I mean? (chuckles)
- Yeah, it's important.
And on a serious note too, I think it's,
I mean what you're doing
by pulling in those pieces
and communicating that
to a large audience,
'cause that makes a difference too,
because I think that's part
of what has to happen here.
We need to have, and I think you were both
referring to that earlier.
We need to make sure
that we communicate that
that is the brain that is
involved in these things
and not lose sight of that
because that's where
some of the stigma comes,
that's where some of the fear comes
and all the concerns
about, if I broke my arm,
I'm gonna take care of that
and get it put in a cast so I can heal.
But if it's my brain, "Oh,
I don't want to touch that."
Just all of the reactions
that come with that.
So I think it's critical.
- Yeah, I think that's such
an area for improvement.
Reducing stigma for mental
health within medicine itself,
let alone within society,
and also of course to make
mental health resources
so much more available and cheap.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, I totally agree.
- I think it's funny because to me,
if I think about like a megaphone,
a megaphone is small on one end
and it's bigger on the other
end, I feel like academia
has the megaphone turn the opposite way.
Like you got all this information
and then it's like, it
just gets kind of like-
- Yeah.
- I gotta get this out
here to the general public.
(chuckles)
- Yeah.
- I love this type of thing,
we're trying to figure out
how to get it out to people.
- Yeah, there's so much there.
- So, on purpose I've
been making YouTube videos
and posting them on
the Yale Medical School
YouTube channel to provide
this information to the public,
to doctors who are not in the same field,
about burnout, for example,
especially during COVID.
So it is my own little way of
trying to get that information
out there and Nii I sent
you one of the links
that maybe you can put it on the website.
- Yeah, I can definitely
put that up on the website.
Great resource, yeah.
- That's wonderful.
- So I know we're running tight on time
but I did want to ask both of you,
what legacy are you trying to leave
in terms of your passion.
I mean, all the things
that we've talked about.
Like how are you trying to
make sure that that gets out
and continues to make an
impact to those around you?
Amy I'll have you, you started
with the YouTube video,
so I'll have you continue
to expand on that.
- Well, I'm really hoping that
we continue to make progress
in creating medications
that really help us
be our better selves, our better angels,
so that when you feel stuck in loss,
there's something you can turn to
that's really healthy.
I also wanted to say
something I discovered
in preparing for today's discussion.
I was thinking a lot about
the power of gratitude
and forgiveness and so I looked and said,
I wonder if anybody has looked
at what happens in the brain
when you're feeling those emotions.
And I found a few studies
including one by the Damasio lab.
And I was so struck that
when you're feeling gratitude
or forgiveness, it
activates the same areas
of prefrontal cortex that Rajita Sinha,
who was your guests last time,
has shown are the very circuits
that help us overcome the stress response.
So a real neural basis
for how those feelings
may really help us overcome
the toxic effects of stress.
- That's so good.
That's so good.
I mean, it goes back
to what I think about,
what we're told in scripture a lot too,
in terms of the importance
of serving others
in some ways it sounds to me
like the neurobiological basis
of what that is doing
and just kind of ties
everything together, wow.
- That's great.
- I felt so too, that it
relates up the song "Blessings"
and religion and science altogether
by activating the ventral
medial prefrontal cortex.
- Wow. (chuckles)
You taught that the way only
you could tie that together.
(Amy laughing)
- Yeah, that's amazing.
- And the day I see that in
the lyric, Lecrae will be-
(indistinct)
(Nii laughing)
- Listen, I don't know what to, I can,
that's interesting that she
says that because my legacy,
I definitely feel like my
legacy is to figure out a way
to process the information
that we currently have
and to shrink the amygdala so that it,
there's gotta be a way
to shrink the amygdala
and to ignite the prefrontal cortex
so that it can communicate
clearly to the amygdala
during stress circumstances.
And I think if I can just write a song
that would allow that to happen
then the whole world is changed, clearly.
That's my contribution and legacy.
- I'm actually a little
bit scared by your insight.
'Cause there are studies that,
maybe not shrinking the amygdala
but they're looking at
those exact pathways.
So somehow you tapped
into something. (chuckles)
- Oh, man, oh,
no, but sincerely I
see myself as a bridge.
I live in a lot of different communities,
obviously the faith-based community,
the African-American community,
the musical community.
And as someone who has
struggled with mental illness,
I've seen the benefit of
the scientific community
being able to speak to these places.
And I wanna be a bridge.
I think that we've seen,
that's not the only
legacy that want to live
but as specifically as
it pertains to this, yes.
We've seen obviously
within the black community,
just like the total, like, I
don't know what therapy is,
I don't do all that stuff
and just them understanding
the necessity of a lot of these things.
In the musical community, a
lot of artists and musicians
are brilliant and struggling
with mental illness
simultaneously, and
they don't even realize
that a lot of their art
is stemmed from depression
or anxiety or other types of disorders.
And so just helping them
understand that relationship
so that they can find health.
I don't think it's coincidental that,
the musician community has
its quote unquote 27 Club
where all these artists
died at 27 years old.
And so, and then obviously
in the faith-based community
to erase a lot of the stigmas as well.
I think there's this misconception
that the brain is not a physical entity,
that it is all spiritual
and so to take medication is unspiritual,
to seek therapy outside of a
pastor or a priest or whatnot
is somehow unbiblical.
And so just to close those
gaps would be very encouraging
for me as something that
I'd strive to be able to do.
And so, yeah, I would
love to see that happen.
And I guess what I would say is this
is that I think that we're all in a band
and too many of us are playing solos,
and we sound a lot better
when we play together.
When all this stuff is mixed together
and now there's information
that is widespread.
And so you can embrace some
of these cultural things,
but then also add the
scientific elements to it
and we're all healthier.
- Yeah, yeah.
Well, I appreciate both
of you for doing that
in your own ways already and
for even coming on this podcast
and doing that in this conversation,
merging the science and mental health
and the faith and community,
I think it's so, so important.
So definitely, definitely
appreciate the way you both
contributed and I'll be
following the ongoing work
that you all are doing.
- Lecrae you're the
bridge that gives me hope.
- Oh man.
- Wow. (chuckles)
- I'm honored, and listen I need you all
to continue being brilliant
because otherwise I don't
know what I'm doing out here.
(laughing)
- We're all working
together for the same cause
in a lot of ways, so definitely
appreciate Dr. Amy Arnsten
and Lecrae, thanks so much
for joining on the Addy Hour.
It's been a pleasure.
I know this is gonna
be enjoyable for folks
to listen to as well,
I think a lot of things
that will equip people too, so.
- Yeah, appreciate it, honored sincerely.
(upbeat music)